une distribution de masques pour les
associations caritatives de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en première
ligne pendant tout le confinement
trois associations située à la verrière
et l'encours et rap ont reçu le matériel
ce vendredi 15 mai l'initiative a été
menée conjointement par le département
est une entreprise spécialisée dans la
confection de vêtements personnalisés
pour protéger des autres il fallait
qu'ils puissent être protégées donc ça
leur permet de pouvoir courir dans
d'action et ça c'est vraiment très
important pour moi et pour mon équipe
aussi qui est très heureuse de
participer à ce don peut pas les laisser
tomber
il faut qu'on agisse chacun à notre
niveau nous en tant qu'élu les
associations or avec toutes leurs leurs
activités caritatives
et puis les entrepreneurs aussi doivent
mouiller le maillot et c'est je trouve
une belle action de mêlée ces trois
acteurs de terrain pour aider les
familles les plus en difficulté au total
l'entreprise a fait don de 200 masques
jetables et sans masque lavables une
bonne nouvelle pour cette structure
implantée dans le bois de l'étang qui
distribuent des colis alimentaires et
une vingtaine de familles chaque mois
les matchs seront distribués à des amis
bénévoles et pourquoi pas aussi les
distribuer aux familles qui en ont
besoin aussi parce que c'est aussi le
but parce que le masque un masque ça
coûte très cher donc si de notre côté on
peut les distribuer à différentes
familles c'est aussi c'est aussi
l'utiliser aussi nativité d'autres
masques de ce type pourraient être
distribués dans les prochaines semaines
à d'autres structures du territoire des
yvelines